it's nice soft dirt I gotta save a lot
of sand in it or some clay not much well
the point of having a fish rack and the
point of having uh a nice cold hole to
store things is to preserve stuff if
you've got all this food and you're
trying to keep a surplus you have to
have a way of preserving it this right
now is just about keeping what we've
worked so hard to get ahold of a good
condition to get it home so you can have
it for the window
if you have it just laying here on the
ground like a hole in the ground your
bear could just part it
weasels can go in it mice will fill it
old-timers used to make them around and
make my square it's got a lot more to go
I'm just getting a basic frame no
I have a duel it's almost there I got
the basic frame up the idea of making
building it and tell people the food's
fresh and keep all the mice away so
they'll go back it's part of living like
we do but so we don't have to depend on
anybody but ourselves ain't much for
jobs up here so you got to make your own
work Kuta nares our youngest daughter
and it's always been a pure joy just to
teach the kids we consider this to be
part of their education they have to
have local knowledge of the local
materials and local foods going to be
there what to do with them and have
storm cut down these willows quite a
while back and they're useful for lots
of things I just need the Willows right
now to hold down the grasses that we've
stacked against it for an insulated
layer
I'm done look it all the way up and back
it doesn't fall on your head not bad huh
yeah you can get into gameplay into
whatever I'm pretty happy with what's
going on
I'll have place to store berries and
greens and use like refrigerator and
have no mice and place over here are dry
foods over I know it's kind of small and
narrow but that's the whole idea we made
it really big it would be hard to keep
the cool until well it's big do cuz use
a little lady